it's about time
after months of mixed messaging
conflicting guidance and flat out
confusion
the cdc says fully vaccinated americans
can ditch masks
and don't have to social distance in
almost all indoor places
anyone who is fully vaccinated can
participate
in indoor and outdoor activities large
or small without wearing a mask or
physical distancing
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic if things
get worse there is always a chance we
may need to make
change to these recommendations today
is a great day for america we've gotten
this far
please protect yourself until you get to
the finish line
after a year of hard work and so much
sacrifice
the rule is very simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do
the choice is yours you all made this
possible
now let's finish the work of beating
this virus
and getting everything back to normal
some may say
just feel more comfortable continue to
wear a mask
they may feel that way so if you're
someone with a mask
you see them please treat them with
kindness and respect
kindness and respect it's kind of funny
coming from joe biden who called texans
neanderthals
for dropping the mask mandate following
the science months before the cdc
finally get around to it
all right let's bring in everybody here
juan williams
he says it's a great day for the
american people
but i have a feeling you still might be
wearing that mask am i right about that
like i went to the ball game the other
night i did wear the mask but that's
required at the stadium that was the
rules
uh to go to the nats game uh but when
i'm walking around i don't i keep it in
my pocket some people
i think we discussed this jesse some
people give you the stink eye if you
know they think you you know you
shouldn't be doing that
i don't but i haven't been wearing the
mask outdoors i mean it was a month ago
that cdc said if you're fully vaccinated
and i'm fully vaccinated
uh that you can run hike walk even be
with
people in small family groups you know
people you know who are also fully
vaccinated with no problems so
you know jesse i just want to tickle you
i want to slap you on the back i want to
say come on man
celebrate today is good times i mean
i just can't believe we're through this
i mean you know this has been a struggle
for
everybody i don't care who you are where
you are and this
is good times i say hats off i know
you're going to get upset at this but
hats
off to the biden administration uh i say
hats off to the people who are
the pharmaceutical people who came up
with this because they
they pulled us out of a mess man who
else won
oh well
all right here it is here it is here it
is thank you
thank you thank you president trump for
not getting in the way
of warp speed thank you you know that's
the best we're gonna get out of you one
that's fine
that's fine that's fine
[Laughter]
not getting out of the way all right
tyrus
um you know i think what is it maybe i
think half the governors have already
dropped the mass mandate so
federal government a little slow i don't
think
you need the federal government to tell
you that
you don't need the mass once you've been
vaccinated but how do you feel about
today's announcement
well like i said it's a you know it's a
day late and a dollar short but i'm glad
we got there
uh anybody who lives in texas or florida
could have said ben told you that bro
uh the the frustrating thing for all
this has been
the politicalization of the cdc and
their excuses for not telling us what
all americans want we just want truth
straight up good bad and different
tell like it is doc don't mess around
don't sugarcoat it
and now they're getting to the point now
we're like well the other states are
doing it and i think maybe this came out
more so because they're trying to catch
up
with the the blues the red states that
are saying hey we're outdoors and we're
we're going to go in the water
regardless of sharks and it works
so now they're saying oh yeah everyone
but it's it's still it's still political
and
it's the sad part yeah judge jeanine did
you miss seeing joe biden's beautiful
face out there today
and uh at the at the white house well
actually i was shocked
i didn't know he won you know until he
pulled the mask down i said yeah that is
joe biden
well look the other thing the the other
thing is look do you remember
when someone asked him uh at the podium
they said if you're vaccinated
why are you wearing a mask and he said
something about your business patriotic
duty
look there isn't which which it is not a
patriotic duty it doesn't seem to me
unless i'm
you know missing something but what did
we learn today that we didn't know a
month ago or two months ago
if you're vaccinated if you waited the
two weeks
you can go outside and actually be
indoors with other people who are
vaccinated
and not wear your mask what is new i
mean what pushed them to this point
and all this panic about you know oh my
gosh at the podium i lost my mass
and then the other thing with kamala
harris kissing her husband both with
mass on
when they're both vaccinated this is
theater rand paul was right
now the other crazy part of it is that
the people who are vaccinated apparently
are the people who are most hesitant
about getting back and doing things uh
that that we've done
normally and so whether it's taking
their cruise
you know going to restaurants if the
vaccinated ones are the slowest ones to
get involved
and there you have it it's in yeah
that's interesting dana what do you
attribute that to
because you would think that those
people it would be reverse
yeah i'm in the reverse category so
maybe it's just possibly
caution or maybe waiting to hear
specifically from the scientists as they
wanted to follow the scientists that
it's all going to be okay now to not
wear a mask
i think we take it as a win like okay
this is great i agree and
i think that when when president biden
said americans have missed each other's
smiles
i think that's true he's got a great
smile kamala harris has a great smile
everybody loves
a smile so that's good um judge jeanine
said something i was thinking about too
which is
earlier this week the cdc director
rachelle wilinsky she testified in front
of congress
um she wasn't wearing a mask yesterday
though john kerry was testifying
and he wasn't worried he was wearing a
mask and so
that was like i would prefer that i
think all of this is sort of strange
now you might wonder why today
i'm not saying but i would admire the
skill
to hold a positive announcement when
every other story and every other
headline
when you're at the white house and every
story is bad you're looking for a good
story that will break through
directly to the american people and this
would be it
yeah smart i admire so do you think
maybe they held this
they held this for a day like today when
they were getting killed with bad news
and then
i'm just saying either they're extremely
lucky or extremely skilled and i admire
it either way
either way all right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else